all of us here at eight news now would  like to say a special thank you to our  news director terry foley that's right  we received a word today that there  would be a change in management terry  was a long time klas employee starting  as an intern more than 30 years ago and  working her way through the ranks from  producer to executive producer and  managing editor and then finally to news  director she has been recognized as  employee of the year and is part of the  klas hall of fame through her various  leadership roles the stationer numerous  awards including a peabody dupont edward  r murrow she is a las vegas native a  unlv graduate she has deep roots here in  our community she always made events  here at the station very very special  from halloween to the holidays she was  always dressing up with her husband too  she will always be a very special member  of the klas tv family so from all of us  here thank you so very much terry  a great boss but also an amazing friend  yes